only thing that stays Wicked and still
ends up on the knife list for the
holidays is wicked Donuts owner Chef
Teddy is back with the sweetest
Thanksgiving feast you will ever have
welcome Chef Teddy hello should I call
you Chef Teddy Santa uh
Senator Teddy works that's fine no can
we just before we get into the donuts
tell everybody where they can find you
as Santa well actually this year I've
been asked to be Santa
Downtown Summerlin at their little
Chalet yeah so come on down it starts
this weekend every day I will be there
for five hours wow I know that is crazy
and you honestly you really are kind of
like Santa because you're just giving
everybody Joy all the time all year
round so let's get into it Thanksgiving
feast donuts can we just get a can we
get a shot of this somehow can you guys
see this
oh are they in oh see they're in the
verse as well you see the pictures here
it is literally a Thanksgiving feast but
Donuts where did the inspiration come
from well you know uh Netflix is is it
cake yeah it is really popular yeah see
all the tick tock trains is it a shoe is
it a cake right so I thought well I can
do that with donuts so how fun would it
be to do with Thanksgiving meal wow all
Donuts I mean you've got the yams you've
got the peas you got the turkey can I
just pick up the turkey please this is a
Fritter actually well it's a turkey it's
a turkey
doesn't it look like a turkey or meat or
something that is amazing look okay
there it is look at that that is
incredible and now you I love that I
love the fact that you call this your
Willy Wonka approach because the
creativity at Wicked is just Wicked we
do a lot of things that that look like
something else like this
cerebral you can eat the spoon eat the
bowl and the cereal and the donut it's
fun that is so cool now what is the plan
for the rest of the holidays obviously
that Thanksgiving do you guys have any
special things coming up for Christmas
and beyond that yes we have a special
Christmas box of course have to follow
this up uh and that also has some fun
little tricks too
guys have to try these out where can
they find you what's the location
9490 West Lake Mead Boulevard okay and
then at the Chalet to get to sit on his
lap and ask him for more donuts come on
down
to you